Coming from where I come from,
you know,
you loan a guy some money,
he doesn't give you
your money, you got to --
you have to seek retribution
other types of ways,
so I feel like they should
just go out there
and line up the fight,
and see what it do.
You know what I'm saying?
Just line up the fight.
It don't even matter --
size don't matter.
Just line it up,
and they squabble it out.
Maybe.
Let's line up a fight,
you videotape it,
we put it on Youtube,
we charge 'em a percentage,
and he can make
his $900 back that way.
Slink, you know what you are?
You're an idea man.
What do you think of this?
I don't know if, as judge,
I can do this,
but maybe I can look it up
in one of these books.
Yeah. Books.
What if I went in there
and told them
that, you know,
just for old time's sake,
they should get drunk
one more time?
And then, when
the defendant is drunk,
the plaintiff can say,
"Hey, can you loan me $900?"
'Cause I bet you he'd give him
the $900 while he's drunk.
Hmm!
Or maybe the defendant
can ask for the $900 again,
and get it from the plaintiff,
and pay him back the first $900.
If he's too drunk.
Exactly.
So it's a win
for both of those guys.
That big guy seems
like he can handle his booze.
Nah, that guy --
that guy
soft as cotton, bro.
You think?
I know it.
I think he drinks
a nice, warm --
a nice cold glass of Chablis,
and he shit-faced.
That's why the little guy
hangs out with him.
You can't really just measure
a person's size
like that, you know?
Right.
I'm not much
of a drinker myself.
I have a couple of 'em,
and next thing I know,
I got some buxom,
180-pound blonde, you know,
crawling up on my body
taking advantage of me.
Oh, that sounds terrible!
It's horrible.
One of those big
Eastern-European thick ones,
you know what
I'm talking about?
They always get me.
[ Eastern European accent ]
"I want to climb you
like a tree, Slinky."
And I let 'em.
Let me see that.
[ Lighter clicks ]
I love that people
might call you Slinky.
Kinky Slinky
with the stinky pinky.
but that was
in my high school days.
[ Chuckles ]
I shook hands
with that stinky pinky.
Mm.
I got hand sanitizer
in the dressing room.
I'm right.
I ain't gonna come in here
and infect you,
you know what I'm saying,
'cause you is a white man
in a robe,
and you might be
very responsible for my future.
You know what
I'm talking about?
[ Laughs ]
I hope I am responsible
for your future
because you're in charge.